-Here's how it works.
We each have cards with
random words written on them
Our goal is to work those word
into the conversation
as casually and seamlessly
as possible.
Does it make sense? Great.
I'll set you up.
-All right, then.
-Here we go.
Hey, Nick, do you have any -
Do you have any plans for
St. Patrick's day?
-I do, actually.
I probably will get myself
to my nearest pub.
I like to get
a pint of Guinness.
And I'll walk or take the bus or
maybe jump on an e-scooter
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Yeah, it's like different --
Your boys going to be
at the pub with you?
-Yes, my boys will be there.
How about you, Jimmy?
-Well, you got -- you got --
you got Darryl, the bank maker
-Mm-hmm.
-You got...
You got Eddie the baker,
you know?
You got Chad the cheesemonger.
[ Ding ]
You got --
Everyone's showing up.
Everyone showing up for
St. Patty's Day.
It's a party.
-That guy puts down some
hot cheddar, you know?
-He certainly does.
-I met him at the
University of Illinois,
in Champaign-Urbana.
-That's true.
-Yeah, we were at this
crazy sorority orgy.
[ Ding ]
Wait.
-I think you told --
-Are we still going?
-No, you told me
this story before.
I've heard this story.
-Oh, I did?
-Yeah. I think so, yeah.
Well, it involved a --
-Did I tell you the weird part
-You told me
the weird part, yeah.
The weird part involves
a walrus.
Hell yeah.
[ Ding ]
Is that the weird part
you're thinking about?
-It turned out
it was not a walrus.
It was Wilford Brimley.
And it was --
There was this production.
It was a touring bus and truck
production of "Mame,"
but there was this weird
Polish lady,
and she kept
pronouncing it "Meme."
You shook the --
something right off the --
-She was pronouncing it "Meme.
-"Meme."
-"Meme," yeah.
It was "Mame," but she was
pronouncing it "Meme."
But it was the production valu
that people liked
about that show.
You know, it wasn't the acting
so much or the sound.
It was the --
it was the staging.
It was the lighting,
the laser beams.
It was the smoke.
[ Ding ]
-Yeah.
-The smoke, and --
-They actually weren't --
They weren't laser beams.
I'm so glad you said that,
because using Plexiglas
cut on different angles
on the edge --
Stay with me here.
You use mini Maglite, shining it
through these different --
And the way you do it is,
you set up --
You can get a single-beveled
compound miter saw.
-Sure, you got that.
-Or you can --
If you got the bread,
you can get a triple-bevel
compound miter saw.
-Yeah.
-We didn't have a huge budget,
so we had a double-bevel
compound miter saw.
[ Ding ]
-And that's what
you used to create --
-That's what -- Yes.
-To create the prism.
-And then you create the -
It looks like laser beams.
-Oh, I love football, man.
I get out there.
You know, I'm talking abou
my man cave.
I get out there in front of th
big screen, you know?
Watch the big game.
You got to have
your snacks, right?
-Oh, hell yeah.
-You got a sub,
maybe a party sub,
a Turkey sandwich.
You got a roast-beef sandwich,
a ham sandwich.
-Right.
-A...
-A bologna sandwich.
-No, silly.
A French fry sandwich.
-Oh!
[ Ding ]
Of course.
-I'll see you at the big game.
-See you there.
-My thanks to Nick Offerman.
That was a great conversation.